-Performing "Spit of You"
from his new album
"Seventeen Going Under,"
here is Sam Fender!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
♪ They say
I'm the spit of you ♪
♪ And they're not wrong ♪
♪♪
♪ Bury my head, too ♪
♪ Stomach hurts all the time ♪
♪ Can't shift it ♪
♪♪
♪ Been like that since 8 ♪
♪ Knotted up with the baggage ♪
♪ Neck like a stone ♪
♪♪
♪ All sounds just like you ♪
♪ Smashing cups off the floor ♪
♪ And kicking walls through ♪
♪♪
♪ That's me and you ♪
♪ I can talk to anyone ♪
♪ And I can talk to anyone ♪
♪♪
♪ I can't talk to you ♪
♪ And I can talk to anyone ♪
♪ I can talk to anyone ♪
♪♪
♪ I can't talk to you ♪
♪ You kissed her forehead ♪
♪ And it ran like a tap ♪
♪♪
♪ No more than four stone
soaked wet through ♪
♪ And I'd never seen you
like that ♪
♪ Spun me out ♪
♪♪
♪ It hurt me right through ♪
♪ 'Cause it was love
in all its agony ♪
♪ Every bit of me
hurting for you ♪
♪♪
♪ 'Cause one day that'll be
your forehead I'm kissing ♪
♪ And I'll still
look exactly like you ♪
♪♪
♪ And I can talk to anyone ♪
♪ I can talk to anyone ♪
♪♪
♪ I can't talk to you ♪
♪ I can talk to anyone ♪
♪♪
♪ I can't talk to you ♪
Hey!
♪♪
♪ And I can talk to anyone ♪
♪ I can talk to anyone ♪
♪♪
♪ I can't talk to you ♪
♪ And I can talk to anyone ♪
♪ I can talk to anyone ♪
♪♪
♪ I can't talk to you ♪
♪ Come on ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]